you all right yes I'm fine fine don't it
look all right you look like melted ice
cream there aren't a whole lot of
professions that demand you rapidly gain
or lose weight to such extremes they
give you gout actors have it rough
sometimes not financially at least not
the A-list ones so today we're
appreciating all of their hard work they
put into packing on the pounds for a
roll when you're gaining weight of just
absolutely losing all discipline and
just gorging like crazy number one
Dicker Montgomery struggled with his
weight as a child but he always knew
what he wanted to be and he worked
towards it and he used The Bullying
experiences to fuel his character Billy
Hargrove and stranger things saying you
know any bully or person that you've had
in your life that has been antagonistic
towards you it was about finding those
qualities and representing them when it
came to finding the perfect body shape
for the role dagger had to shift away
from his Power Rangers body he wasn't
aiming for Billy to be perfect he didn't
think his character would need to be
super toned because bodybuilding wasn't
as big in the 80s and Showtime
number 2. Brendan Fraser has returned to
acting and is rejuvenated and ready to
try something new he admitted if there's
no risk then why bother in the whale
Brendan Frazier did gain some weight but
the rest of the transformation came from
Prosthetics and CGI he found he needed
to move in an entirely different way it
took 10 years for them to cast the
project he said My Hope was that I would
become unrecognizable I didn't have to
affect or rely on through any CGI we
didn't use any of that really he was
carrying around 50 to 300 pounds of
Prosthetics while filming so much in
fact that he was actually gaining muscle
from it number three David Harbor has
consistently fluctuated in weight over
the years for different roles and it has
not been kind on his body he lost over
75 pounds to play prisoner hopper in
stranger things then immediately needed
to pack back on the pounds to play Santa
in violent night
foreign
all this up and down is not good for the
body and I'll have to give it up soon
but it is such a fun part of the job to
live in a different version of your skin
for a while number four Mark Wahlberg
had to gain a ton of weight and fast the
actor was cramming in up to 11
000 calories per shoot day to gain 20
pounds in three weeks for his movie stew
we didn't even know that was possible
this is a picture of you filming the
movie right and then three weeks later
and this is not I'm not making this up
this is a picture of uh Mark he said it
was fun for about an hour it's such a
hard physical thing to do losing weight
you just kind of tough it out you just
don't eat and exercise and this even
when you're full I would wake up after a
meal and have another meal I was eating
every three hours it was not fun having
only 30 days to film the movie really
packed on the pressure he's only got
himself to blame though as he was the
one financially backing the project
number five for Natalie Portman's role
in Thor love and thunder training took
about 10 months in total she had to
condition her body for the first four
months before even beginning to bulk up
just so she wouldn't injure her joints
it's like all this extra time you're
spending you know working on your role
Natalie is a vegan but she eats very
well despite this on a natural diet she
just could not get enough protein in her
and had to add in some vegan-based
protein powders number six Tom Hardy
gained over 30 pounds to play Bane in
The Dark Knight Rises he managed this in
just over three months he pointed out
that if you study the photographs you
can tell he isn't all muscle he was
bulking up by eating pizza truly he
admitted further they shoot from low to
make you look big so people would see
him and say I always thought you were
bigger but the truth in his words I was
just bald slightly Porky and with pencil
arms number seven Christian Bale is done
with the extreme body weight
fluctuations but we question how
committed he is to keeping that promise
he even said it himself I keep saying
I'm done with it I really think I'm done
with it yeah the fluctuations are really
taking their toll he's gone from eating
as little as an apple and a can of tuna
a day to scarfing down one pie after the
other his most recent weight gain was
for vice he gained 40 pounds and he had
a lot of regrets about it I need to stop
it it's not healthy for your body
apparently Prosthetics have come a long
way in that department and he could have
saved his body the struggle number eight
the story of Ryan Gosling gaining 60
pounds for a roll is rather fascinating
and frustrating because he gained all
that weight chugging back melted ice
cream day in and day out and then was
replaced by Mark Wahlberg Gosling has
stated he was replaced in The Lovely
Bones due to gaining too much weight but
the story is more complicated than that
it came down to a communication error
between him and the creative team in the
months leading up to filming but there's
been other stories surface about him not
being the right age for the character
and also just the good old creative
differences story but what did the
writer have to say about it they
insisted with the right effects work
they could make Gosling work and Gosling
insisted it wouldn't work and no the
effects just weren't working and Gosling
got the boot or walked out who knows
number nine Zac Efron has struggled with
depression due to his body Baywatch was
a challenge for Zach his trainer Patrick
Murphy said the physical training was an
ever-changing approach but he also had
to do lifeguard training hiking biking
obstacle course training and more
Shifting the training consistently
ensured Ephron never once plateaued the
trainer found Ephron to be one of the
most dedicated hardest working people
he's ever trained sadly Zach was better
at dealing with the physical than the
mental challenge admitting that Baywatch
look I don't know if that's really
attainable there's just too little water
in the skin like it's fake it looks
cgi'd number 10. Chris Hemsworth was
cast as the God of Thunder for a reason
but the story of his stunt double is far
more interesting to keep up to Chris's
Peak physical form Bobby Holland Hanton
must eat the equivalent of 35 times a
day Hanton said I also have to train
twice a day Chris is naturally a monster
and all he has to do is look at weights
and he grows Chris and Bobby have been
pretty attached at the biceps these days
doing many movies together beginning
back in the days of Snow White and the
Huntsman in 2012. Hanson has also been
the double for Chris Evans Captain
America number 11. Pattinson has
criticized forced body transformations
in the past but his tone changed quick
when he was cast as the bat beefing up
for the Batman movie Robert Pattinson
found that he had to get over that six
week aggressive training mode before he
really started to enjoy working out at
all he said it's all about pushing
boundaries and building up to a point
where you know you can do justice to the
physicality required taking on a full
physical transformation as well feels
even more exciting on top of your
standard workout routine he did a ton of
boxing and even some military type
workouts on the beach number 12. Jared
Leto is probably one of the most intense
actors we can think of you've probably
heard about how much work he put into
morbius taking an extreme amount of
interest in the blood disease his
character has having to both lose weight
to look sickly and then regain that
weight for after his transformation
basically how did you go from the before
to the after uh macaroni and cheese the
director said those Transformations
sometimes it looked like they would tear
him apart true story he got Gout and his
cholesterol skyrocketed while preparing
for chapter 27. gaining or losing weight
rapidly or unhealthily can come with
serious consequences that's the takeaway
here be safe with your diets alright
lots of veggies get your protein hit
your calorie intake we've got to say we
didn't expect these transformations to
come with such intense feelings about it
what story surprised you the most let us
know in the comments